[Music]
there were a bunch of taboo words
growing up in our family [ __ ] naughty
words naughty more than taboo i would
say uh is naughty worse than taboo
i think so isn't taboo like adult
naughty naughty's such a cutesy way of
saying taboo right i think taboo is
cutesy
oh you do taboo sounds cuter but naughty
is like nothing oh you see you associate
naughty with like sexual maybe maybe
maybe well should we start this again
nope okay
well um speaking of things we shouldn't
say
to people publicly the number one was um
using the name uh jesus christ as an
expression of frustration as anything
other than
just saying the name of the person jesus
christ it is one of the ten commandments
and we grew up very catholic and one of
the commandments was thou shalt not take
the lord's name in vain so in vain would
be like just not with respect exactly
like if you stubbed your toe and you
said ah jesus christ yeah
mom see now were you triggered yes i say
it a lot you know why i say it a lot as
an expression a because it was probably
taboo but really because it was set
michael j fox said it i'm blaming him
but in back to the future there's a
great moment when he tries to pick up
daca's back in time comes back from the
future in the delorean and and the uh
drivers what is it called the uh
driver's license license plate license
the license plate is like a scalding hot
and he goes to pick it up and he goes ah
jesus christ doc you incinerated
einstein point is
mom if you're listening just know that
we're gonna be saying the name jesus
christ but not as more than a few times
in this episode just so
let that be a warning okay good that was
a nice morning it wasn't really a story
but it was a warning life could be a
dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i am
your jesus christ fearing host justin
long life could be a dream sweetheart
you don't fear jesus christ well a kind
of i mean he's such a benevolent i i
don't but if but if that is all true
uh and and i and i you're not it's a sin
to take the lord's name in vain to say
his name in vain but i'm really [ __ ]
no you're not because jesus christ if
what they say about him was true
he was uh
more than anything a forgiving
person i know so he wouldn't hold that
against that's a hard thing to recognize
that was always this strange um it felt
like a paradox or something about about
the ten commandments is that right there
are all these rules
that you're supposed to abide by like
the most important rules
and
and the guy in charge is like this is
this rules completely forgiving i know i
never well you know the way it really
made sense you know the way mom and paul
would explain it probably and i don't
want to speak for them uh but it would
be well the ten commandments are old
testament and like once the new
testament comes around they kind of like
amend all the lessons you're supposed to
learn in the old testament they use the
lessons and they become allegories and
and jesus is like
oh you don't have to do i mean like as
an example he hung out with um
you know women of the claw not of the
cloth no that's the opposite the
opposite of the women of the rubber
women of the robber um women of the
night yeah yeah prostitutes you can say
prostitute i think so you know that
should be respectable
it's the oldest profession i know i know
anyway well the reason i don't want to
shame sex workers the reason we're going
to be talking about jesus christ is not
because we're potty mouths not because
we're going to say it in a naughty way
that's because we're going to be talking
about the
musical jesus christ superstar i think
it might be my favorite
really i think it might the music
is it's hard to beat that that music
it's definitely in my
top five dear evan hansen is that in it
maybe hopefully future guest um
[Music]
uh that's up there for me i like that a
lot but see
uh it's still relatively new to me
whereas she's crazy superstar i've loved
for a long time and i remember when they
did it so we're going to be talking um
to one of the stars of the
latest
iteration
incarnation of jesus christ superstar
the one that they did on i think it was
nbc yeah the live the live with john
legend
yes our guest is the our very special
guest is the incredibly talented
christian and i are uh we're holding
back because we're big fans and we don't
want to overdo it um i may have overdone
it in the interview i'm just gonna say
that that's a disclaimer i can't wait if
you don't like gushing um our guest
today is sarah bareilles
sarah is an incredible singer and an
actress uh come to find out
she was as we've been mentioning she was
in jesus christ superstar she played
mary
and uh if you haven't seen it you really
should it's god it's one of the best
things i've seen mary magdalene yeah
what would i say mary oh magdalen yeah
not married not the mother of jesus no
no no not that she couldn't have played
that i'm sure she could have she could
play anything anything yeah but um and
she was also in waitress the musical she
was she wrote yeah wrote the music for
uh and she's a great singer all around
she's known for hit songs like love song
and gravity and
and she is now at a show on the peacock
channel which is i think a new channel
right uh yes not new does it sound like
new dude it did always a new always
sounds like nude yeah
i gotta get my head out of the potty and
um that's so taboo of you i know i'm not
just a little naughty guy it's called uh
girls five eva mm-hmm funny produced by
tina fey and it's a very funny show very
funny oh and as a quick uh funny
disclaimer to this interview
sarah was kind and also an example of
how kind and generous she was with her
time
uh we actually did this interview in
three different parts the first being
when i was in north carolina at the
studio did not work and there's no wi-fi
and there's just there's that fail
number one classic north carolina sick
and that doesn't hold true for the whole
state but in this one particular studio
in wilmington it did not work so we
tried again she was kind enough to come
back on we did it here at our studio in
our house where she where we are now uh
our wi-fi went out did not work
fail number two did you start to feel
like oh man the universe didn't want you
to talk to sara yeah that something was
conspiring against us talking and that
like you know i don't know what the
lesson would have been like just enjoy
her music and i don't know what it would
have been but but happy ending you we
did it worked on the third time yeah and
she would again i mean so you might hear
you'll hear it it'll make sense it'll
make sense but like you'll also maybe
hear hopefully not too much in my voice
how um how bad i felt uh because it was
yeah and so again we if she's listening
sarah thank you once again for your
generosity of your uh your time three
different times so here it is uh all
stitched together by the genius mich for
your listening pleasure here is the
angel the generous angel sarah bareilles
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again boom and nobody will
meet
[Music]
yes oh finally hi
hi
i i was just thinking it might be funny
and i'm glad i didn't commit to it to be
pretend to be annoyed at you for being
like 10 seconds late after
after what i put you through wait i need
to know where were you because in my
mind
you were in
a tiny you were like in an on an island
somewhere and oh yeah cause you saw some
of it you could you see me you could
just see parts of it it was dark and
then there were lots of people coming in
and then it was like you were struggling
yes the wi-fi wasn't working and they
didn't they hadn't figured out how to do
this there was no screen or anything it
was a
strange situation so i'm sorry for that
i'm sorry i actually it was a godsend
because that day in particular
long story short i was leaving the next
day for a 10-day vacation actually yeah
and the
just the timings of the day it just
ended up being like i got this extra
hour that i wasn't planning on that was
like freed up so much space so it
actually i'm in a much better head space
to chat today than i was then great
oh good
oh good i'm glad sarah because i was so
eager to talk to you i i'm such a fan of
yours oh likewise just likewise you went
for 10 days to hawaii yeah but for ten
days we were um on oahu in honolulu for
two days and then we went to maui for
eight days and it was just oh man
man it was great
that's great you caught this uh lunar
eclipse
that happened there was a full lunar
eclipse and we got it on top of the
haleakala crater that's on maui and so
it was like
it was like
tatooine she was like landing in star
wars it was crazy yeah
oh i love that
that's such a clear visual reference
yeah
uh and if i always say if you're gonna
see a lunar eclipse do it on the top of
a crater that's i've that's i've heard
you say that yeah so this is my thing
i do i mean this is an annoying like
cliche question do you surf is that one
of the reasons one of the draws no i
don't serve
i have a what i like to call a healthy
fear of the ocean
i'm not a i'm not a super strong swimmer
so
i just like stay i even get like a
little like
my boyfriend took a video of me like
going into the ocean and i
i like
unbeknownst to me and i'm like i just
i am the personification of nervous
energy i'm just like oh god and like on
my wet and like oh god it's a wave
getting too strong
when you saw the video was it a surprise
that you were were you more nervous
looking than than you even felt or was
it
i never i never
moved through the world the way i think
i moved through the world
so it's a challenge to be someone who
like gets
you know videotaped and photographed i'm
like wow that didn't come out the way i
thought it was right in my head i was a
lot cooler right well that it's
surprising to me because you you do seem
and i i hope this doesn't embarrass you
but you do seem really
cool in your just your recordings and
your
your concerts you always i've seen a
bunch of your stuff and you seem so
relaxed and confident the way you
interact with the audience um you often
have people sing and join in and you you
do you're very funny and you seem very
carefree when you perform
is that not after all i i think it you
know that is one of the places where i
probably am the most comfortable i love
being on stage and i've i think it there
really is a lot of merit to that 10 000
hours thing where it's like i really
have spent
so many many many hours on stage in
front of an audience
at this point a very familiar
and like beloved space to be in i bet it
seems that way what does throw you then
i mean what's in the rare occasion that
you're thrown
and
you know you're wobbly you get wobbly or
does that not happen um i think you know
public speaking is like a deep fear deep
like seated fear of mine and i think
and whenever i tell those people it's
like
like oh but you seem so comfortable in
front of people and i'm just really
it's like as soon as i'm supposed to
speak about anything with authority like
the only thing i'm good at is making
stupid jokes and like interstitial
monologue between i
oh my god do i
outside the music thing i relate to that
so much i i uh
yeah i i can get up and do bits and i
have a
narrow window of like a comfort window
but um
that's what it is it's funny i've never
really
been able to articulate it's anything
with authority outside that that narrow
window is is terrifying totally and it
could be something that i
feel very passionate about and yeah
actually talk to an audience and i have
so much admiration for
you know people as i've over the last
handful of years kind of embraced more
like activism work and advocacy work
it's a space i really
want to be good at i just
like my hits are sweating and i'm like
no mess i know it's so odd i know i i
was i got to introduce i did some things
with bernie sanders a couple years ago
and i got to introduce him at uh at a
rally in brooklyn and
tons of people there in the park and
you know i've spoken at things i've done
stand-up type stuff and hosting things
i was shaking i had i had everything
written out and and i thought i would
just kind of speak off the cuff and i
found myself um like it was my first
time talking to people yeah
uh that level of like nervousness and
losing track of where i am like shaky
voice really odd totally there's there's
like my imposter syndrome gets really
loud
in those times where you're like
nobody wants i think you are
yeah yeah how'd you get in here yeah
let's check your bracelet
um
when i picture humboldt county it's like
i'm sure this is the cliche but it's
it's weed and it's kind of hippies posts
60s uh
comfortable but but liberal
was it quiet was it that am i picturing
the right thing
i think there's absolutely
elements of that that are very true
there is a lot of weed it's not
everywhere like i i didn't grow up in a
household that
used marijuana at all so
for me it wasn't like
but i had plenty of friends whose like
parents were stoners so it would it's
not like it was so unusual to see but it
yeah humboldt county is this really kind
of interesting dichotomy of
a little bit redneck culture and and
then this like very
liberal progressive kind of hip dip
um
ideology as well so it's it's
interesting we are very conservative
people and very very
liberal progressive minded people so did
you have friends who were kind of
spammed all of that
oh yeah i mean within my household we
have very certain kind of people and
andy was like
wow
and so what was there what did they
think then when you
wanted to pursue something uh creative
what was that um frowned upon well that
actually was kind of fine i mean my mom
and my older sisters so i i grew up the
youngest of three and then my parents
got divorced and my dad had a daughter
with his second wife and everybody's
real copacetic like good friends and
that was all
like very progressive minded actually
like very proud of my parents for how
they've moved through
um their divorce it was kind of amazing
um but my mom
and my sisters were always involved in
community theater and so
being a performer was
like
a part of our language within the
household yeah too so um you would see
your mom in in plays you grew up
watching oh yeah yeah oh yeah mine too
really yeah yeah yeah yeah do you
remember like being a little kid and
going to see like oh yeah um seeing like
noel coward play i remember she did like
blythe spear i remember more adult type
plays seeing her and it it would always
confuse me a little bit when she had a a
husband like a very and he was always
very they were heightened there was i
remember thinking like why are they so
loud and
they're being smoked my dad is not like
that at all and it's weird that she's
holding his hand and
yeah
but i grew up with that yeah
i remember seeing my mom in a show
called the dining room and there's a
scene in the show where
the adults have to act like children and
they go underneath the dining room table
and my i was watching my mom play a
little kid and i was
i was in hysterics like my i was
laughing so hard and my mom's like i
almost
couldn't remember my mind because i
could [ __ ] yeah
and it was hilarious to me just
like a little kid
so was she but was she like that in life
was she playful was she good at like
telling stories like reading to you and
stuff oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
great very very animated she's a
wonderful hostess she would throw great
parties like we would have really
imaginative birthday parties and
remember one year my my sister
they went to hawaii
at my house and they like everyone had
lays on them
they got little um seat or motion
sickness pills which were m m's my mom
ran a pharmaceutical
company oh no no not really
no she like pretended she was a flight
attendant and took the kids on a flight
to hawaii and it was cute
yeah oh my god that's really cool when
did you know you were good at singing i
mean i know that's just
i don't know it's kind of a silly
question but but like i always wonder
that about really great singers like
do you remember was there a moment where
it was like oh my god i'm i can do this
i
i think it was just um
maybe more so than having any kind of um
understanding of whether or not i was
good
it was something that i loved
i loved it i loved singing with my
sisters and particularly we would do um
like three-part harmony on amazing grace
or like christmas carol like i always
loved christmas time and when i think
that when i think back i think it was
because
we did like a lot of singing and like
singing around around decorating the
tree and it was like very
musical
um and then as i said
um
no not as much i did a little bit when i
got into high school i was in a um
i was in a a little singing group an
acapella group that we started
a couple of my like classmates and i
started we called ourselves a splash of
color and our whole gimmick was like
wore all black and then everybody chose
a different color scarf so it was oh we
were in high demand let me tell you
that's good my brother he wanted me to
ask you about a cappella because he he
was in a group and college he loved
acapella oh my god
do you he wants to know if you prefer
the sound of
of co-ed acapella to all women or to all
men he wondered if he had a preference
oh
well i love the richness of co-ed
acapella i just feel like you can get
the
sort of the range of
of sound but i think that there's
really
so many incredible groups like that
i i don't know that you would always
totally know
like there's some women out there who
are like staying real base where i'm
like wow i can't even believe your voice
can do that and
um the only thing i don't like about the
what i see in
some of the acapella and i think i'm
guilty of this too is that it it gets
when it gets recorded sometimes they
over
perfect it they over produce or it gets
like
you know tuned within an inch of its
life and
um and i really love this sort of
organic sound of
voices singing together it's so and i
went in college when i started with my a
cappella group awakened acappella
um we i remember feeling like
i found my people i just like i couldn't
i couldn't believe how how
much i i didn't know what i was missing
until i started singing in that group
and then they became my closest friends
and i was just so fulfilled by that
what well you must have to be i mean to
be that close for those harmonies too
you must have to be so
in tune i mean and not literally and
also you know it just energy-wise you
must have to be very kind of closely
tuned to one another
yeah i think you do you spend a lot of
time together but i think and people who
who sing acapella music will probably
relate to this it's like it's also this
like slight sense of delusion like
everybody in the acapella group
feels like we're the coolest people in
school and
meanwhile back at the ranch everyone's
like you're in the acapella group yeah
nerd yeah completely but it just like
felt
i mean amazing just euphoric
oh no hey can you hear me
oh i'm glitchy i'm frozen i can see
myself frozen this is truly a nightmare
i feel like there's there's like a
bigger force at work here or something
right someone doesn't want us to do this
well where were we were talking about
what we were talking about acapella and
then
the transition into i mean to go from
like loving singing loving acapella in
college to
i mean that's a leap that so many people
want to make was that when you were
there were you thinking i want to do
this for a living was was it that direct
man i think you know when i got i went
from small town eureka california we
talked about that a little bit um and
yeah day two i think
chapter two
chapter three um yeah i when i moved to
la and
boy i really was
excited by the
the current
of the entertainment business in los
angeles in a way that i don't think i
was quite expecting i was like it was
i mean it was fascinating and it felt
like
oh could i possibly and then but i was
so early in my ucla years and i was
really shy in certain ways
especially about music i didn't
i didn't really like play my songs for
anybody at that point oh so you were
certainly weren't ready to say to people
i want to do this for a living or maybe
even to yourself yeah
no i would like play songs in my room i
mean in my freshman year i didn't even
have i would sneak into
the music rooms in the music department
on campus i didn't do music i went to
the
music placement exam i thought oh i'll
take a music class i love music
and the theory portion of it was
i mean i'm putting in quotes so hard it
was like right out of g major scale but
i literally didn't know any theory so i
was like i just gotta i turned the test
over and i left the test i'd left the
placement exam which was stupid i should
have just like answered what you can
answer yeah put you somewhere right you
see where you were put yeah but the fear
of rejection maybe yeah yeah
i don't know so i didn't end up i just
would i would sneak into the rooms and
i'd play the pianos and then people
would eventually knock on the doors and
be like you don't belong here oh i
thought you were going to say the
opposite
oh no not at all oh i thought i thought
it was going to be like a good wanting
situation and like wow
where's that sound coming from not that
he um it was we i was also doing math on
the walls which was also weird and
so in a lot of ways
yeah and while you're a custodian well
but you must have been people must have
heard that
and thought i mean
you must have been good is what i'm
saying i mean i know it's hard to answer
that probably without sending you there
i don't i don't know if they're i didn't
get that sense in the moment i think
everyone at that age is so so obsessed
that nobody's really paying attention
uh-huh but um but in the acapella group
for example it was like i would you know
get the solos sometimes they were pretty
evenly spread out but like we sang one
of my songs in my acapella group i had a
song called gravity
and we did an acapella arrangement of
that song so you were writing back then
yeah okay i was writing but i wasn't
sharing it very often uh-huh yeah i was
writing how do you connect with an
audience in such a intimate way i i
guess is there ever
you know i think i got
positive reinforcement really early on
with actually that same song gravity
that was one of the first songs that i
had written about i wrote it about my
high school boyfriend who like broke my
heart
and and
i i was so disappointed in my ability in
my inability to like not call him back
or i actually i felt like there was this
gravitational pull towards this person
and no matter what i was saying to
myself internally
and all my like
self-righteous feminist views i'm like
i'm still gonna [ __ ] drive over there
right now yeah like it was just it was
miserable it was miserable but um i
couldn't it was like a drug but everyone
talks in those terms i mean every that's
the beauty of your music and music in
general i think it's like
yeah yeah it like gives language totally
a universal truth yeah and
i think that um
that early
song was a
was one of the first times that i could
see that the more i could be willing to
share my deepest vulnerabilities the
more there was like connective tissue
with an audience which made me feel less
alone which made them feel less alone
which all of that was just like positive
reinforcement i'm like well i feel
better
you feel better this is all just good
news so i started being more and more
kind of confessional
in my songwriting and i think that that
has only just continued your shows feel
that way like they're
i mean in in the best way in like a
really lovely way they feel like
everybody's kind of feeling these things
together
my friend always talks about people
there's two categories of people there's
wet people and there's dry people and
like i am a wet person i cry
all the time and so i don't necessarily
cry on stage that often but i
i have big feelings and music has been
a literal lifesaver for me because it
gives me a place to process
these really big and
uncomfortable feelings well i felt that
in when you played mary i mean i felt
that in jesus christ superstar i think i
was about to i think it was like a
weirdly good time for us to end on
chapter two when we did because
because i was on the verge of um
really getting into it and probably
embarrassing myself but but i i it makes
sense that you have that you say that
about yourself you have those feelings
it makes sense when i consider
how much you made me feel uh and still
whenever i listen to that sound that
soundtrack but seeing it was like
was that something that you was that
strange to connect to somebody else's
writing somebody else's words or was it
just such a powerful story that was like
oh i'm in it
you know it was interesting because it
came right on the heels of
one of the runs i did in in waitress so
i i think waitress was this really sort
of beautiful bridge towards
telling someone else's story but it was
still in my
voice in some way
um
i mean in that i wrote the songs for it
but i
but then i got to take on the role of
jenna
and
kind of tell this story that i didn't
write
and the these songs that i did write but
i was trying to interpret someone else's
work you know so
um
i think it was an interesting bridge
into then going into jesus christ
superstar and
there was such care in that production i
mean the the material is so
[ __ ] genius they were in there they
were like in their early 20s when they
wrote that [ __ ] it is unbelievable it is
unbelievable
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining one replus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
it there are rare performances i'm
getting goosebumps thinking about what
you did in that show uh where where it
is impossible to act you can't act that
level of like
warmth and purity and
having seen it i just knew you'd be a
warm you'd be
the fact that you channeled that so
effectively without like doing it
you and it was you delivered in such a
[ __ ] direct pure way you did such
justice to that music uh that's
kind
it
i gotta stop i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
cutting myself off i love it oh my god
i'm so appreciative i know i felt like a
really i mean that was
such an unforgettable experience to do i
mean it's like the super bowl of musical
theater right here it's like the one you
got one shot at this everybody's
watching don't screw up but the coolest
part about making the show
i'm well i mean the vibe backstage was
just electric but um you know you have
brandon victor dixon he is nuts
astonishing
and john legend and they had
you know a tremendous amount on their
plate and they were both so cool as
cucumbers i'm like well i cannot i'm not
allowed to be
nervous or i don't know if they were
like shaking on the inside but they
really presented as being very put
together so i was just like
okay i just have to drop in and tell the
story and the words the the material is
already perfect so just you know it
doesn't need anything you don't need to
do right so you really just do that one
performance
yeah i mean we did i guess there's a
dress rehearsal so i guess it kind of
felt like two
because there was somewhat of an
audience for the dress rehearsal or
there was an audience for the dress
rehearsal so they could check out audio
levels and cameras and how how it's
going to work with people in the seats
and stuff but yeah it's just the one the
one live performance good lor and how
long what's the rehearsal process like
how long i think that we had two weeks i
think and i only did
i did they rehearsed more days than i
did because i was still in waitress and
so i was missing the first um handful of
days of rehearsal
but um
we had just an awesome
the company was so wonderful the band
was incredible
and and david lebeau our director
was so great in the room just it was a
very warm safe space to tell this very
tender story obviously it felt that it
was really beautiful it seems like that
might be and that's [ __ ] that final
image with the cross
disappearing i mean you see me on the on
the footage like i'm actually crying
it's oh it's all moving in the moment oh
moving yeah really
oh that's right because again yeah
you're i you're only seeing you're
seeing it really for the first time all
done together wow oh yeah and like with
the lights in there and then you know
john's voice and what i mean obviously
the story itself but yeah really moving
oh so it's interesting to think about
just that one performance so in that
sense it might be there's something that
kind of lends itself to really
fully investing and like immersing i
mean you can really be yeah wow you
don't have time to like try [ __ ] out
yeah
how long did you do waitress for a long
time
i've done it i guess four or five
different times and usually for around
two months at a time so i'll go in for
10 weeks or eight weeks or six weeks or
something like that
i've done it in london i've done it on
broadway a few times
yeah it's i love i love doing it so much
that show is just like that's my baby
it's exhausting the you know the the
broadway schedule is absolutely oh man
just
i couldn't believe when i started
working in the theater that i was like
you know musicians we think we're
working so hard
like
we have the cushiest jobs ever like
these theater
actors are so dedicated and so
disciplined and
they do so much work it's incredible
it's wild i can't imagine
doing a musical though having adding the
voice element on top yeah having to was
was that something you had to retrain to
do that level of that level of
commitment like in terms of just
technically
yeah it's you know it's a little
different so i'm used to touring
obviously and the slight difference that
is actually kind of to my benefit is
that in the show you know jenna's
character is singing maybe six or seven
songs over the course of the night so
there's not as many like if i go on tour
i'm singing
21 songs and they're all me and so i'm
singing a lot
but it's like a muscle your voice is
like a muscle and
it does take i have to be really
rigorous about sleep and hydration so
you can't go partying too much when
you're in the broadway show yeah you
feel it huh you live like a monk yeah
yeah i i tried one night oh i'll never
do it again uh one night where i was
like you know what we've been on for two
weeks i have some drinks all right
tomorrow night we don't have a matinee
seven o'clock um
and to be that level of hungover to be
that's something i never want to
experience again um
my thing with
when you're in the run of a show
the paranoia about getting sick
is not something that i i miss right it
is this low grade panic at all times
that somehow you're contracting
something and now people are gonna have
to do it after you know post-pandemic
all of those things that you already
feel where you like
okay i don't touch anything i don't kiss
anyone i like i've it's it's a paranoia
for sure
the last like really gushy question
slash
just gosh is when uh your cover of
yellow brick road
yeah oh my god i'm so glad you liked
that well that's quite an understatement
let me get to it
um
well i had i loved of course the
original but um
a friend somebody played it and i was in
a beautiful study i was already in like
a really i was on a lake and like it was
like a transcendent moment listening to
it
for anyone who hasn't heard it who is
still listening to this uh
like stop this right now and just hear
it is really um
incredible just
i still think about it and get emotional
uh do you
but more importantly do you know what
elton john they're so curious what elton
john thought of it
he loved it i got so i got to know elton
um a little bit i did
a charity event that he runs for breast
cancer uh
fundraising awareness and fundraising
and so he's a breast cancer attorney and
i did um
their fundraiser gala and i sang that
song for john in the room and he was and
he's saying gravity with me no
we got to we befriended each other and
he's
when i talk about who really shaped my
life as a musician he is one of the top
three it's like oh yeah billy joel elton
john carol king oh wow johnny like you
know it's it's oh yeah those are the
people that i really really
studied
and um
how surreal oh yeah he loved it he loved
it i think he loved that
it was um you know a slightly
there was
there's a more
interpretation of it but it i think it
does which is sort of how i approach
what i'm doing to cover i'm not as much
interested in a total reinvention
because i feel like as as someone who
makes songs yeah i'm like well i did it
that way for a reason right right right
i got too much of it
it's nice to honor
sort of the original structure and the
song is that song is just such a joke of
itself anyway so um in a classic you're
making like
chicken parm like you want to keep
certain like the tomato sauce
yeah exactly exactly oh now he he he
loved it
that was like you know a plus for melton
uh it's how how surreal must that have
been yeah how cool but you mentioned
those other um inspirations well now i'm
curious if you were to do
i'm curious about joni mitchell if you
were to do a cover of if joni mitchell
what would you pick
well
if somebody like from the audience
requested like a spur of the moment
i think it'd be california uh yeah it
might or might be case of you oh
hear them
yeah
um
case of you
was one of the songs i listened to over
and over and over again in college but
california
was
i think i knew case of you to be honest
because it was on the practical magic
soundtrack do you remember that movie
with uh i do remember the movie i
remember the soundtrack i didn't know
that really
i think it was
it was on that soundtrack um
but then in my third year of college i
went away to bologna italy and i i
studied for a year in italy and i had
this kind of mystical
moment where i rediscovered
well i discovered joni mitchell through
by way of this um
it was a small jazz orchestra maestro my
friend michael brusha who still lives in
in bologna he was an expat who like
lives he lives over
in italy and he has for a long time and
i
i was in a deep depression i was like
couldn't figure out why i just didn't
feel okay i was desperately homesick and
i went out in the middle of this
horrible rainstorm to find this tiny
music studio because someone had told me
that there was a music studio i didn't
even know what i was i was going to ask
for piano lessons or something
and the lid or the um the gate was
pulled down and it didn't seem like
anyone was really in there i knocked on
the door anyway and michael came to the
to the door and he could very quickly
hear i mean i was speaking italian to
him but um he could very quickly hear i
had an american accent he was like oh
where are you from and we started
speaking in english and it was such a
relief to just like
connect with someone yeah so homesick
and he had me sit down in the back of
the piano and we just started talking
music and i played him a couple songs
and i played him gravity and then he
played me california by joni mitchell
and i just remember my back was to him
and i was facing the keys of the piano
and i was just weeping i was so it was
there was something about like
remembering that music can hold all of
this angst and all of this fear and
depression like there's a place to put
it well will you take me as i am
strong on it oh god yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
so that was uh that that song i think
just has um special significance
what a beautiful story what a great
story and that and it did that um
okay yeah i i those moments i know those
moments also through your i mean as so
many people do now through your
your music um
funny segue though uh case of you now i
also want to hear you do if i were in an
uh if i were if i may be so bold to
request the song um i would i would love
to i wonder what you think of joan baez
and you have a
there's a look i don't know a feel a
joan baez sometimes um but diamonds and
rust
amazing that's okay just put that in the
back here okay i'm gonna put that in the
back
and when it happens you'll know it's
because
forget it i'll have a heart attack oh
i'll seed your name in there somewhere
oh forget it it'd be a game over that's
the last thing i want to hear before i
leave the earth um a case of you though
it's funny
segway if i can make it
can't talk about a segway you just have
to make it right um but my
mind's so so far so good but my brother
and i we uh our frank here we wrote a
movie called the case of you about
whatever the song factored in uh heavily
this guy was trying to learn the guitar
and he wants this girl that he likes is
her favorite song
and we couldn't get the rights
so um
yeah well i mean it was just so
expensive which is why
i'm sure yeah we weren't practical magic
um but
we um
so we had to we replaced the song with
with diamonds and rust and that then
became which i love i [ __ ] love this
but but the director was cat coiro the
director of that movie ah
no way yeah weird right small world yeah
i love cat oh my god i fell madly in
love with her what uh what a
she's loving it she's a firework she's a
firework she's a lovable firework yeah
and i uh this show's so funny it's um
your the new show on peacock called i'm
not telling you you probably know this
already girls fight
yes yeah
it's called girls five eva you should
check it out you're in it it's so weird
to look at somebody and say that uh yeah
cad busy phillips is really funny i mean
you're really like the anchor of the
show um
and and funny so funny like really like
broad but done in a grounded way and
um it's great but what is that something
that you wanted was that deliberate was
that like i kind of just want to do i
want to do a funny thing oh no it was
just like another i felt like it was a
lifeboat but tina fey reached down from
the heavens and was like
let me save your life with this other
new left turn that you never thought you
were going to take it was i mean she i
got a phone call
well i guess the script got sent through
management and then i had a call with
tina and meredith scardino who's the
creator show runner
and
um
it was in the middle of the pandemic it
was i think it was around june when we
spoke
so i
was in a really bad place and i i think
i was i mean i was here in new york city
the the city was
emptied out it would it felt apocalyptic
the novelty and the charm of staying
inside all day
was like [ __ ] out the window i was
like
please bring me my straight jacket
because i i'm
losing my mind and then i got this call
and i had a friend who was going through
chemo at the time one of my very very
best friends my
just like 20 year best friend
and he passed at the
end of last year and
so i was just like like i was so many
layers of what was happening um and then
i said yes of course because it i was
like this is the like could not be a
more perfect recipe of all of my
favorite things not only do i look up to
both tina and meredith and i'm a fan of
their work and what they create
um but it's musical jeff richmond is
writing the music for this it's like
it's just gonna be
and then i didn't know
i mean i was the i think i was the first
one on board so i didn't have other cast
mates to respond to but i was like
whatever this is i'm in to try this you
know take a big swing
and then when we started shooting
it was just it felt like a miracle to be
at work to be able to go i like we were
all i think
cast crew executives everyone was so
present to the feeling of what a
privilege it was to work at all because
we'd all been just like sitting at home
yes doing puzzles or whatever yes making
bread
and i
i was just so grateful i was so grateful
yeah yeah yeah i remember that feeling i
remember hey kat felt similarly funny
she was staying at my place in
massachusetts where i first heard yellow
brick road you do yellow brick right um
isn't that odd her family was that was
at my cabin up there and uh that's
amazing yes i remember her talking about
being in massachusetts at a cat that's
your place my place yeah but i remember
there was some
she would have moments of like and i
don't think i had worked yet uh and i
was chomping at the bit obviously and
like was it was you know really living
vicariously through friends who were but
there were moments where it was like
because of all the coveted restrictions
uh it was like god we have to now wait
um a week we can't get that location i'm
sure you remember like things shutting
down but
she said and i experienced this later
i mean my level of patience for [ __ ]
like that for things in general it was
like
i mean it's like through the road like a
different person uh they appreciate you
said it the gratitude the appreciation
for getting to do that totally yeah i
mean we got tested every day every
morning you have to get your results and
then go and like yeah and and and there
was a tremendous amount of patience for
even just like the protocol and when it
would shift and what would change
you know our first ad steward yelling at
us all the time to like keep your mouth
face shields on and like and you're just
like
everybody's just doing
their job and they're trying to make it
so we can actually get through the end
of this totally and we did miraculously
yeah and well it's i'm glad you did it's
really it's so good um and is that
something that might continue is it
would you want it to continue
a thousand percent oh okay desperate to
get a season two oh good okay well
we're we've been so lucky the response
has been amazing we got great reviews
yeah we're loving the show and
um
it's so fun it feels like comfort food
to me it's like good you know it's it's
fast and funny and it's the way tina
sort of like pitched it to me was like
if you if you're a fan of 30 rock it's a
little bit of like the rhythms of 30
rock with a warm a slightly warmer heart
yeah so it's it's got a little bit more
more heart but it does it's high jokes
per minute it's true it's tricky
it's really fun that's a wet it's well
said yeah it is a hybrid of that and a
lot of the heart is provided by you i
would say by you and your character and
um it's yeah but still you're right the
dense it's dense with funny
um that's awesome yeah yeah so i think
you know everybody we really tried to
make because it is so zany and it's so
much fun to play like
you know but i think my character you're
right is sort of the one that's like
holding the strings of the balloon yeah
exactly
the maniacs but it's also all that stuff
must have been from the flashback stuff
uh for the because it's about a girl
group that was around in the like early
2000s i guess um yeah like late night in
the late 90s yeah destiny's childish
sort of thing um
it must have been fun to just because
that was probably like a formative time
for you it must be it must be just fun
to spoof that i feel like some of those
some of my big fantasies oh yeah a life
in the music industry
i'm actually getting to live out now
totally 41 year old woman who like had a
career like has a career in the music
industry and
and i'm getting to like put on those
crazy outfits that i never
was even i wouldn't even have considered
wearing at the time it was just too
too much too flashy but you kind of
looked up too but you kind of admired
you thought it was cool completely oh my
god i was obsessive about britney spears
and aguilera but i was i always knew
that wasn't me yeah but i i was such a
fan oh yeah but now you get to you get
to try on the pants that's really cool
yeah literally and they're low riding
and just they show you about crack
revealing it yeah yeah the thigh what
are they going to thought yeah
i'm proud to say i don't know uh but
and so and how does that now compare
interesting in the in the wanting to do
it and in the joy the newfound
appreciation uh are you are you that
much more excited about playing about
touring again
oh my god yes i just did um
i just did the i guess what was
at least one of the very first live
shows back in new york city at the
beacon theater oh no
a charity event
for love rocks new york city
a benefit concert that benefits god's
love we deliver yes i love that meal
delivery service yes
they do incredible work so we do they do
this huge concert and it's um i just
john bon jovi and gary clark jr and yola
and myself and emily king and
um
got all kinds of wonderful people
brought together and
um it was like a thousand people in the
audience oh man and it was wild
it was amazing it makes me so excited to
get back in the audience i bet so
excited yeah i'm glad you mentioned them
god's love we deliver yeah people should
check out it's a really great yeah meal
delivery and it was
so needed you know obviously during
coven it was a huge asset to so many
people um yeah how cool cool you guys
did that um uh okay i would lightening
round and then
until episode four
i lose you uh thank you too truly like i
really appreciate you hanging out i'm
curious how much of the um in the
editing how much of the technical i
think you have to talk about it right we
have to i think one of the i mean what
really disappointed me i was really
kicking myself after the second one
after chapter two uh
because so much of that i spent talking
about can you believe what happened
after that first time you know and like
going on about the [ __ ] studio and
like how it didn't work for me and i was
like uh that was such
wasted
time i was just talking about how i i
had messed up
no it was all meant to be life could be
a dream sweetheart
[Music]
right now prime members can get four
months free of amazon music unlimited to
enjoy 70 million songs
obviously you probably wouldn't listen
to them all at the same time but you can
enjoy those songs whenever you want on
demand and ad free that is their best
offer ever so go to the amazon music app
or
amazon.com
life is short to get started it's a
limited time offer new subscribers only
terms apply
hello hello
we'll meet again
[Music]
what is your lightning do fast then
you're out of here i swear what
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say your go-to the heart the
red heart
yeah um
this is not in it but out of curiosity
now uh if you were to do a cover of
billy joel
what would it what do you think
she's got a way
a powder i love that's right keep going
don't know what it is
i'm terrible with lyrics i just did one
of these like song association things
for l magazine and i
was
appalled at how i guess i don't have a
memory retention gland i don't i like
don't remember lyrics
of anything but can you just go in there
is that what you end up having to do
yeah yeah
in fact on your live album i think you
don't you lose sure i think that's the
lyrics at some point i think they're so
funny
i'd be the same way minus the angelic
voice um
i would just forget things uh if you
could be a professional athlete what
sport would you play
uh
oh god lightning okay oh no yeah
basketball yeah basketball yeah no i
don't really no i think it would be
maybe
soccer
okay
good answer i don't care yeah that's
what i'm getting that's what i've
gathered
that's what
i didn't want to answer for you but that
was how i interpreted that yeah you
don't i guess i'm like i don't want to
run that much
i don't want to do either well
hockey maybe okay you should wear so
much gear
i don't want to the next question all
right can i i'll i'll sing for them okay
great yeah the national anthem well have
you you've done the national anthem at
stadiums yeah and i to be honest
i don't like doing the national anthem
because i
i have a little bit of issues that it's
always it's just all about war yes yes
like there's a better version of what we
say about our country but yeah i also
just the pressure of that i i'm even
though i've sung that song many many
many times i just i feel like i'm always
going to forget the lyrics and then the
pressure of it is so good
right but and also the the forum it's
like people are there to see
people place a game like they're not
there for that it's like getting to the
thing they really want to see
that psychologically must be weird um
yeah i agree god uh so my brother just
asked if if you had a year and i'm
curious about this maybe we should
incorporate this if you had a year to
train
uh which olympic event do you think you
would be best suited for i mean it's
like he had to
like you have a year which olympic event
he said archer
i thought like luge because you could
just sit in the thing i was thinking
about the luge too but what's the one
where they like scrub the oh yeah that's
a curling which
another friend of our said but
apparently that's like
really not to [ __ ] on your answer but
apparently that's really hard to do
any curling heads out there
i guess for and are we just is it is it
winter olympics elementary no either one
it's got to be
in the olympics though
hi joe okay okay
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life like you're you're
just [ __ ]
uh guilty whatever is this pizza count
or is that too much of a meal uh yeah
it's a meal but who cares
you want to okay snacking pizza i mean i
could eat pizza for everybody oh really
every morning noon and night is my
favorite
and you're in new york now
yeah so what's where's your place i have
a few okay so my my old neighborhood i
lived down um in nolita and ruby rose
had pizzas down there and ruby rose
if you can get it
fresh yeah don't [ __ ] do the delivery
thing you have to go eat it or go pick
it up and eat it on the street like it
has to be fresh
ruby rosa their classic pepperoni is
maybe my favorite but then
now i live uptown and there's a place
called mama's
up here and there's we're kind of close
this place called mamas too and they
have a deep ditch pepperoni
really it might it might knock it might
not
mama's two
mama's two okay like mama's as well oh
yeah yeah oh good to know okay really
good to know i love asking really
amazing amazing amazing pizza great um
and what is your favorite what a movie
that you would love to introduce if you
had a kid uh when when you have a kid if
you're if you have a kid a movie that
you would really like be eager to
introduce them to like oh man i can't
wait for them to see this
princess bride oh yeah yeah yeah i think
that movie is just that it's such a
cliche answer i know so many people love
it i just it's my favorite yeah my
favorite it holds up i know
it's just incredible it comes on all the
time and every time i have to watch it
you know i it's so comforting it's like
yeah seeing an old friend you know yeah
um for some reason it's been in my head
lately uh that a moment in that movie
where peter falk's looking for his
glasses do you remember the angus yeah
okay okay
i don't know why um
what is your um what's your goat how's
it interesting to ask singers this your
go-to karaoke song
if you were to do karaoke
yeah it used to be a son of a preacher
man oh man i'd love to do that i love
that song i love that song um
oh [ __ ] the other night i heard
i heard pat benatar we belong oh yeah
i'm like oh maybe i need to do this song
oh man i love that song ah
even if if we were friend we'd hang out
socially you couldn't i you i you
couldn't go to a karaoke place but i'd
be i get too weird
when you're saying i find karaoke is
very stressful
i've gone in japan when it's like the
private it's like yeah in the private
room i i almost
i can't say that i enjoy karaoke
i really enjoyed karaoke when we used to
do it we used to do it once a month
after after waitress on the broadway
stage and we did waitress karaoke no we
would invite fans up and they would sing
excerpts of songs from the show with the
waitress and they would do their so it
would be their broadway debut
they're singing a song from the show
that they love oh that's cool and it was
really really fun yeah oh what a great
way to uh enter i'm surprised you don't
like it because you'd be so good but
then i think you don't also don't want
to always take all this pressure
i get like i'm like do i sound okay is
there a reverb it's like too technical
did you ever go to marie's crisis you
must love it there yes
i do love it there all right not to sing
really but just i love yeah i love the
environment yeah soaking it up um uh who
was your first celebrity crush
i think probably
leonardo dicaprio uh-huh
yeah yeah i was very um what's eating
overgrown
was
the or i don't did titanic come first i
think romeo and juliet was before
yeah that whole yeah one two punch
on a leo bender and we're like writing
letters you know try to be like clever
in the letters being like i would write
it in my diary like you'll see diary
i'll make him mine that's so funny i was
just talking to a friend my girlfriend
about about this about leo and like the
love of which i completely get there's
the yeah
romeo the talent and the yeah how could
you not but it's funny to think of how
many
people had that how many yeah women um
who
who was uh what's your favorite fruit
apples
a really good honey crisp apple honey
crisp yes
delicious uh and if you had to get a
tattoo uh i don't know if you have any
but if you had to get another one what
would you get
i've been thinking about this actually
because i i feel like i'm might be
orbiting getting another tattoo and i
i think
i would do something that is a reminder
of my meditation practices at this point
it's something to the effect of like
begin again or
you know
yeah sarah
with the same person i was talking about
leonardo dicaprio romeo and juliet i was
talking today about that about that
specific
um
moment in meditation because i'm just
starting this thing called ten percent
um
that's my [ __ ] chair no
oh my god you gotta get get on the
podcast with dan harris yeah
podcast i'm i'm an avid i like i'm
i'm a preacher oh man
enough good things about the app and
about
the podcast and all the work that
they're doing it's incredible i'm so
agree i'm new i'm very new to it but it
i already feel like you know a
transformative uh effect yeah and begin
again i love that i love the idea of
well you messed up
yeah begin again you just have to yeah
reconnect yeah
um
yeah funny uh and who would you want to
play you in your biopic
meryl streep uh okay yeah wow why not no
um
i'm sure everybody says meryl streep no
no one has
well i i think let's see
i don't um what's wrong with meryl
streep playing you i like that answer oh
no i mean she'd be [ __ ] incredible
i'm just trying to think of like meryl
streep gets all the jobs
one other person to get a job oh that's
really yeah um
who do i just maybe one of the um maybe
alana glazer oh yeah oh funny yeah
yeah i don't know somebody like
who's like he hasn't got to do that kind
of thing before
yeah yeah yeah uh biopic i like a lot
yeah and you have a similar vibe
she's funny and yeah i i feel like you
want someone who has a little bit of
them
who's
not that she is a mess in her real life
but that's that's what i know from that
quality of her character yes she's like
someone who's like got a little bit of a
mess yeah like fun chaos kind of yeah
yeah yeah um
who uh
and do you have a favorite simpsons
character we used to ask favorite
muppets character i don't know if you
grew up watching the muppets
yeah um
who i'm trying to think if i ever had
like a real favorite
someone you like gravity i mean
yeah i think i was a real like i had a
real soft
well maybe beaker oh [ __ ] that's smart
yeah
again he keeps coming up my brother who
i did the show with uh his fiancee keeps
calling him beaker and he's like oh
thanks a lot she's like oh in a fun
movie so lovable yeah
lovable quality yeah yeah maybe beaker
funny that's great good answer um uh
dogs are cats
dogs dogs do you have one yeah
no but we're kind of
circling chewing on that i just
yesterday in our elevator we were coming
up and our neighbors were coming down
with two dogs oh man we're thinking
about getting them and the guy looks at
this dead eye and was like don't do it
you know it's funny
can't you catch you on a bad day yeah
jesus what kind of dogs were there
they were too big
and i think that they must have just
it's hot here right now forget it yeah
my god my i had a dog a big dog and in
the city when you have a big dog in the
city i mean winter debt of winter or
dead of summer is like yeah
you could take care of them it's like
hot poop on the side you know peeing on
a great and like shame yeah and people
walking around them the dog shame yeah
they're so real
i feel for them i want to give them
little doggy potties yeah they can go
into yeah a little like you know cover
uh beetles are the rolling stones
beatles for me yeah and i'm curious what
song you would do of theirs like um
or if you're just at a bar you want to
put a couple on the jukebox
yeah um oh god there's so many i mean i
have done covers of oh darling because i
love that song
[Music]
and i'm a real melody
like
i was going to say [ __ ] but i don't
remember real melody
um i just love it so much i'm really
i love it yeah yeah i got really go on
the ride with the beatles oh yeah i bet
the stones some yeah um a bit of
nerdy music trivia so that song keeps
coming up too i love george so much and
something was the first song that he got
on the album or or like oh i didn't know
that or like the first like on track the
a side i think of an album um
and he so doubted his skills as a writer
because of the dynamic in the group you
know because he couldn't get music i
usually they won't let me have one songs
and that that he almost gave it to joe
cocker that song
yeah oh that would have been beautiful
too i know i know yeah i know wow
yeah wow um
uh ketchup or mustard
ketchup yeah
are you a vegetarian why do i think
you're a vegetarian no
all the meat okay good go ahead
and and what are two adjectives you hope
people
use to describe you when you've gone
when you're
when you've left this earth
um
[Music]
funny and kind yes
yes well you've been both
to me
truly thank you sarah thank you so much
oh my pleasure to join connect and to
chat
i'm a fan oh man
well you know likewise i don't have to i
think i've established that that uh
maybe too much
um but this is really fun each time
uh
he should be see you next week
tuesday at a regular time
um and we're gonna plug the [ __ ] out of
uh girls five ever be a because it's
real it's genuinely really great and
funny um but also i hope just as a fan
of you as someone who likes you i hope
you get to keep doing it oh thanks me
too me too yeah appreciate it um cool
well thank you thank you so much and i
can't wait to see you out there playing
i will be in the audience screaming
requests
yeah yeah profane requests do [ __ ]
gravity yeah
thank you have a beautiful day you too
thanks sarah bye bye
well done
[Laughter]
well that just happened
oh it sure did i did i'm glad you guys
like twinkle
whimsical look in your face
oh my god i can't believe i was about to
do that was she um how about when she
was
singing just like a couple notes of
songs like when i was asking about like
hypothetically what would you sing
uh-huh oh yeah
she's always
like keep going
she's always a woman oh my god oh my god
is that what she's saying the billy joel
one uh she's got away she's got away
yeah exactly yeah as beautiful as her
singing voice is
she also has a remarkably beautiful
speaking voice she does i noticed that
yeah really quickly of course of course
i know there's something so like breezy
and you know cool and
soulful about her you know she has like
a real ease well and like a cool
confidence what you know what a friend
of mine got me in who also has the same
ease and confidence into this great app
did we mention 10
yes i'm telling you i i've only done it
a couple of them i'm on just i'm short
while into it but it's like you seem a
little chiller
the last uh
how long you like a few days you've been
doing it yes yeah i truly it helps you
be more it's you're mindful of and i
think people who she's been doing it
sounds like for a while you're mindful
of what you say there's there's a you're
more connected to the to the moment to
the present that's what it's all about
it's like connecting to the pres so i
imagine it makes you i think that might
be what you're hearing of course i
didn't know her before she did this but
um
i think it makes you a better
conversationalist more connected yeah
like she doesn't push anything no i know
but she but that's also how she performs
or i mean her performance in in so many
things but but in jesus christ superstar
is like
you said to her and you were absolutely
right that it's there's something
present and and there's nothing forced
about it it's just like she's there and
she's not trying to do too much but it's
so real like it's such an authentic
wonderful performance i know and i
almost never
want to use that word for it wonderful
especially it's like one it's like it
made me like
like full of wonder watching that
performance i recorded you listening to
it i mean i have the proof it's really
funny we're going to play that after i
yeah
i mean so much of it because we listened
to it
we were so full of wonder that um i have
a lot of that recording i mean
this conversation with her uh that you
just had was it could have been a lot
weirder i thought yeah you know in a way
that those interruptions actually helped
because it was like it forced me to just
get back on track and not like be too
indulgent with like how much i loved her
music i
was impressed by
how little you were gushing compared to
how you probably wanted to but
you did in like kind of a muted way
you were
very complimentary
for a long time it was exciting you kept
it was it was like a modest amount of
compliments that went on for a long time
yes you know so you weren't like overly
effusive at any point which was good
but you like wouldn't drop it you're
like okay i'm going to be in the front
row in your next concert
you start to get a little like steve
stark and
waiting for duffman yeah
mike the genius michael hitchcock well
you know you know what it was i think is
um i want to be honest but i also don't
want to make her uncomfortable and i got
the sense from her that
i just i got the sense she might not
like right but also that's true i i
think you're right but i also think that
she's not the kind of person who
exhibits false modesty exactly so yeah
she won't be like oh no don't that's not
like she'd be able to take the
compliment yeah
even when like you said about elton john
what did he think of that
uh her rendition of yellow brick road
which is incredible like amazing and
it's like of course he liked it but she
said instead of saying i don't know i
think he liked it you're right
she was like he loved it i'm telling you
it's honesty it is there's something so
disarming about and it comes up a lot on
the show and it's like we often say like
oh it's this combination of
she's kind they're confident but without
being douchey yeah and i think that is
the
that's the difference it's if you are uh
if you're just being honest and and you
have the skills to back it up i mean i
know
it makes sense that elton john would
have loved it it's a it's an incredible
version of of his song i mean it's r
it's more than doing it justice like
anyone with ears would love that exactly
right
right exactly it's incredible you didn't
talk about this but she was one of the i
do just remember this she was one of the
judges on
the sing-off which was oh really a
pretty short-lived show i think it was
maybe three seasons it was it was an
acapella
it was like american idol but for
acapella oh
yeah yeah that's where um you know
pentatonix
that's everywhere
they i think they're starting there oh
you love that show i love that show i
love acapella
um another reason why i love her
because she's like one of the best she
was like
famous in collegiate acapella oh really
yeah she was and she was being a little
modest when she was like you know i got
some solos and they played
she was known
yeah she was like an incredible acapella
and ucla had a really great acapella
what are you called i'm forgetting now
but that show was great and ben folds
was one of the judges oh yeah you
remember that
sean stockman one of the boys one of the
boys two men oh i would love to hear her
cover a case of you wow
there's also a lot of california
pretty much anything were you gonna are
you did you hear what i like saying a
little bit of it yes i didn't even sing
it because i knew you were gonna listen
you're like calf
oh my god i know i want i want to just
hear her
singing everything she's singing the
phone book oh my god
and that and that song has been covered
very well i think by some people like
yeah uh james
hopefully future guests hopefully yeah
but hers would be amazing oh and and uh
who else covered it
he was the original
winner of the voice that's right shout
out it was like the kelly clarkson
equivalent
uh on the voice she was the first
american idol winner and he was the
first the voice winner remember when we
did that um
that show where we had to watch i was
with him celebrity party i always want
to say like death match or something
celebrity watch party celebrity where we
just to watch these shows and the
producers kept being like all right um
it was like this time last week yeah
maybe
you're like really excited by this
episode and i was like yeah maybe i am
but that's not how i express excitement
so
yeah that's where we discovered um and
they're like well maybe dude a little
bit they kept referencing raven simone
because raven was like you know she's
exuberant
and they were like
oh do we you know because raven did it a
little bit like this like when she saw
this you know that the guy get hit in
the face with the pie she was like damn
oh whoa like
i know but that's so raven but that's
not so christian i just
stupid that's not
that's a little too raven
yeah we get making those jokes with them
and they're like
yeah so anyway if you could just be a
little bit bigger then the final cut was
just us like the two times we were like
yes it's two two i know one was i think
genuine but i do remember them using one
where i was like ah [ __ ] it they they
have jobs to do they want us to do this
thing and like they got
all these people set up stuff in our
house like we got and i and we like kind
of want this to be over so we were like
damn
oh schmidt oh
damn oh by the way speaking of uh
our family feud's coming out soon oh it
is the uh season premiere was last night
oh wow cool oh i can't wait they're
gonna let us know right i think so
they'll want you to promote it oh yeah
that would be it would be raven of me to
promote it that would be so raven of you
um she loves pizza i like how much she
like pizza and i realized that a good
future lightning round question
should be would be
uh favorite pizza topping oh great is
that a good one we should start doing
this should start doing that that's a
great one
i i i'm always curious about i'm always
curious about people's pizza orders and
where they like and i have from i my
go-to pizza topping is pepperoni
you don't both have to have your go-to
pizza and be pepperoni i just had some
though you had leftovers from pepes and
i just had some a slice of your
pepperoni pizza shout out you're getting
into shout outs yeah pepe they feel good
they do
especially when it's the thing that's
brought you so much joy like puppies has
brought me a lot of people oh my god
they have one in new haven and one near
us in fairfield in british there's a few
of them there's one in um
uh
hartford i believe there are a few of
them well sarah if you're listening to
this still i hope you are yeah check out
pepe's next time you tour around here
um you want to read a letter okay from
jessica subject fan from philly hi
justin and christian i'm so glad that i
discovered your podcast during the
pandemic it brings joy to my life during
a rough time thank you so much jessica
it brought joy to us during a rough time
it makes me wonder if i should finally
start podcasting because i always wanted
to but did not know where to start like
many others this year i've experienced
grief anger frustration isolation and
exhaustion all hitting me in different
ways and for different reasons with the
state of the world recently can all get
too much sometimes i'm sure a lot of
people can relate um i feel like there
is so much suffering and there's so much
more i can do to help finding a podcast
like yours brings joy into the world and
allows me to realize that it's okay to
escape for a bit i'm uh public interest
attorney oh in philly and i'm in the
midst of a job transition i am one of
the lucky ones because i have temp jobs
while i look for full-time work and so
many people are struggling for work your
podcast brings much needed laughs and
i'm always telling stories about the
podcast the point people tell me okay we
get it you like a podcast
that is funny it's so nice and so nice
and funny and it's funny to imagine that
she's actually by being so nice about it
is maybe turning people off yeah it's
funny to think that there are people out
there who are annoyed by
that without having heard us yeah it's
just this that just hearing our names
yeah thanks to a very strong i don't
want to hear about that guy justin long
anymore the la i hear about it so much
at work the last thing i want to do is
go home and listen to it so thanks
jessica but truly thank you uh one of my
favorite parts of the podcast is the
small clip at the end very end where you
are chatting with families sometimes
about the simplest things i also really
love when christian breaks down the
interviews and how it naturally brings
out a jolly riff between you both and
how you engage in genuine discussion
with one another
did she write jolly rift or riff riff oh
good did i say rift i i don't know i
couldn't uh jolly riff yeah okay okay it
is a jolly riff you know jolly rift
would be
yeah a rift can't be jolly maybe it can
a rift between like santa claus and his
sibling
um
the clauses
uh you
i i don't talk to my brother uh
chris crickle any much um
cody kringle
we had a bit of a yeah we had a riff a
rift
um you love to laugh with one another
and it really shows sometimes that may
seem small but also something i love is
how justin transitions from the very end
of the guest interview immediately to
the lightning round and says what's your
favorite emoji no matter what the guest
was talking about sometimes the
juxtaposition between the last thing
said in the interview and the emoji
question goes from heavy to light and
for some reason it always makes me
giggle i agree with that that is funny
it's often very funny well it's i guess
the worst i do it the less of a segway
there is the funnier it probably is
um
thank you both and your team for the
show and i hope that you guys continue
it for a long time well thank you
jessica and i hope i wish you luck in
the job transition it sounds like i mean
you sound very smart and you have great
taste
so uh i'm sure you'll
you'll do uh it'll be a smooth
transition i'm hoping it is um here are
two would you rather's great two of them
one would you rather have a pet that
lives less than its average lifespan but
has the ability to talk with you every
day
or would you rather have a pet who will
live twice as long than average but who
does not have the ability to talk with
you um
you know we've had versions before yeah
but what is
what does it mean to live less than an
average well let's say you know a toad
lives six years i love how you go right
to toads but i think about pets
well all right uh pomeranian oh boy oh
what would a palm right you don't
you don't want to go there you'd rather
have a toad
yeah i would
no but listen listen
i would go so far as to say
i would rather have one day
with a pet that i can talk to
than
a double lifespan of a pet i can't talk
to you i think it just shows how
how not eager i am to have a pet and how
fascinating it would be to talk to
animals it would be but also
imagine see it might be a bit of a
sentence
uh to talk to to be able to talk to a
pet especially for like half its
lifetime because even that like let's
say you have a tortoise i mean they can
live some live over 100 years
uh that means for 50 years
what if
what if they're kind of an [ __ ] i
mean what if you're or they're like
shaming you for not and also like here's
what you can do with pets though
you can uh give them up for adoption you
wouldn't want to can you imagine giving
something that can speak up for adoption
if he was an [ __ ] still i mean no no
if he was an [ __ ] if i had an [ __ ]
tortoise i wouldn't i'd be able to give
him up for adoption or just let's say
they're not an [ __ ] let's run pet
finder tortoise who talks [ __ ]
lovable house trained
we'll live for at least another 40 years
um
yeah but let's say they're just they're
totally
fine they're like benign they're they're
friendly enough they're nice enough and
they're like you know that you get along
with them but then when it comes to
they're like let's say it's a dog let's
say it's like you know an australian
shepherd and it's like uh
i might mate would you mind uh taking me
out for a uh gotta go for a
number two
number oh yeah i you would want that
because then there's no guesswork
because often with dogs you have to i
know but think about whether or not they
have to go to the bathroom but then
you're going to be so easy but then
you're in its company when it's
it'd be like
you mind looking away it doesn't matter
you're in this company anyway what's the
difference you're saying you would it
would be like too personifying i yes i
would it would be weird it would youtube
like a human yeah yeah yeah for sure i
already do treat dogs especially i mean
like humans you know that's true i i
know you're saying but i still think the
thrill of the throne i'm able to
communicate with an animal that's i
would stop the having a pet for a long
time well that's why i would do a day
too but i don't think you're looking at
the like potential pitfalls of if you
had half its lifespan which is uh it
doesn't say half it's like it's less
than i said no less less than its
average that's what i was wondering what
that means because you pick how long it
is yeah okay if you could i would
probably pick like two weeks with a
talking toad
yeah oh you picked toad no i'd pick uh
probably a hamster whoa i like hampshire
you're trying to like make it right with
maggie now no no i do like hamsters
really hamsters have large testicles
you'd have to talk about that with the
with the hamster yeah yeah what's there
to talk about well what do you like
having hunter yeah i didn't you'd show
them yours and be like whoa yours
compared to my body they're much
i think i'd be embarrassed to show a
hamster my testosterone
i think i would be if my testicles are
relatively bigger than the hamsters yeah
but they're but relative to my body
they're much smaller who cares it's it
it might just make the hamsters see
things its own it might see things
differently but it's not going to shame
you for having like small testicles
because yours would be it'd be like as
big as it
is that the end of the letter sorry okay
number two would you rather have the
ability to read other people's minds but
have no control over whose mind you can
read it happens randomly or would you
rather have other people be able to read
your mind and you can control who it is
that can read your mind oof oh man
that's definitely the first one yeah
definitely i wouldn't want even people
who i felt very close to i wouldn't want
anyone to be able to read my mind yeah
it would feel violating and there's
something like it's the one private
thing that we all have well it's our
thoughts yeah which is why kant said we
can never truly know anyone well you
have been meditating thanks um yeah and
and i would really enjoy the randomness
of the first option of being able to
uh who am i gonna drop in it it makes it
more exciting yeah i would love that
option actually yeah who yeah whose
thoughts am i gonna hear even like
really benign thoughts i would be fine i
prefer that maybe yeah yeah
um that would be really funny the the
only thing that suck you wouldn't have
anyone to share with but you could say
what it is yeah exactly that'd be an
amazing ability anyway uh so back to
jessica with love
and from philly jessica thank you what a
great letter really good would you
rather um
thank you jessica and thank you uh to
our very special guest very special
sarah we are we remain we we're bigger
fans now yes
if that was possible i don't want to
speak for you you don't both have to be
bigger fans of cerebrals after having
heard her speak on a podcast she's
amazing and um and if you guys would
like to write into the show like jessica
did our email address is life is short
at wondry.com and
if you haven't seen
the live jesus christ superstar or
waitress or jesus christ five eva do
yourself a favor or the sing-off yeah oh
well in that order maybe sarah thank you
and thank you especially for all of that
time your patience and um and for your
wonderful music yeah for sharing your
gift with the world
it's a hell of a gift and we these two
middle-aged nerds really appreciate it
it's really enriched our lives and uh
thank you to everyone listening because
doing the show enriches our lives yes
and we'll talk to you next week
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long oh
smooth it's co-hosted by you christian
long and it's also produced by you and
it's also produced by megan v monaco
senior producer is michelle miesh lans
audio engineer on this one is sergio
enriquez and executive producer credit
goes to the one and only marshall louie
it's all done for a company that some
people like to call wandery
[Music]
doesn't she write music too
yeah oh and this guy holy [ __ ] she's not
the fullest
oh she was yeah oh you must really
and she's oh this choose the judge while
the
oh yeah
yeah i'm a big fan
[Laughter]
oh my god i'm like a huge fan yeah i'm
surprised you don't talk about it more i
think about it
you do that's a big friend how big a fan
you are like yeah you're like
you don't want to like talk about her as
much as you think about her because
you're afraid it'll be like weird
i'm like a fanatic yes
yeah i don't think he knows how to i
don't think he's ever been i just looked
down on him
what is he doing
why is he so relaxed she's trying to get
him to be relaxed maybe he was told to
do it
they are closed
[Music]
and this guy
god
[Music]
[Music]
you know you go from one thing i know on
the same night i know
i loved your
way you do your cardi b
and because i'm such a generous person i
released a bonus episode of life assured
where i chat with darius rucker who you
may know as well you know him as an
incredible musician i once knew him as
hoodie
uh from with his other band mates the
blowfish and you can find it exclusively
on amazon music right now